hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
over the last two weeks I've played more
Red Dead Redemption - than I'm going to
admit and during that time the sheer
volume of Easter eggs to discover has
taken over my life here's fifty
references to film TV video games and a
few cultural cameos - if you ready let's
do this film references in Red Dead
Redemption - are plentiful and start as
early as the second train heist in which
the gangs plan and execution of a
robbery are almost a shot-for-shot
remake of the scene from the
assassination of Jesse James by the
Coward Robert Ford damn us a long ass
title
[Applause]
[Music]
during a side mission activated down in
Saint Denis you'll locate this chap
Marco Dragic
he's based on the real-life inventor
Nikola Tesla at his home in the woods
you'll see many references to Tesla and
his film counterpart played by David
Bowie in the prestige if you haven't
seen that film you need to hit it's
bloody brilliant the laboratory in Red
Dead matches up almost perfectly
Marco Dragic also borrows from
Frankenstein and uses his skills to
create a child he's not a monster like
Frankenstein he's a lovable robot
slightly inspired by many attempts at
robotics from back in the late
18-hundreds and beyond probably the most
famous is the Tin Man from The Wizard of
Oz if you choose to continue this quest
line you'll see a reference to the movie
AI
another movie referenced early on is
maverick complete with a gambling scene
which turns into a shootout it's a
Western centered around gambling on
riverboats and here in Red Dead where as
unlawful as they come off the film under
video game end up in a gunfight what a
surprise this arguably a couple of Lord
of the Rings our Hobbit references in
Red Dead Redemption to the famous Hobbit
house can be found in the wilderness I
say arguably because these homes did
really exist back then but I do believe
it's a nod to the book or the films
remember The Hobbit scene where the
heroes are literally barreling down the
river and reach a waterfall well someone
tried this in Red Dead Redemption to buy
the main bridge washed up to shore is a
young lady who wasn't so lucky
this also could be in homage to Annie
Edison Taylor the first woman to go over
Niagara Falls and survive she wasn't so
lucky this time around ever seen the
film Cowboys and Aliens yeah it's a real
thing well that Western is honored in
Red Dead locating this building you'll
find a note on the table the note tells
us to return at 2 a.m.
doing so will net you this UFO sighting
exiting the Shack will cause the UFO to
scarper here's a silly one I can't
figure out I need your help
over in Valentine it's possible to perv
on two lovers as they're about to do the
dirty deed when one says this I'm
certain I've heard that line before but
I can't remember which film any help
would be appreciated anyway stop looking
you dirty pervert a random event can
happen when passing stone formations
it's possible to see three men
attempting to escape their incarceration
this is a nod to the movie brother where
is forced you into life heading this
wanders if you've seen brother where art
thou you'll know about the KKK in that
film and sure enough they are here in
Red Dead Redemption - there's a couple
of interactions to have with them he is
my favorite do you choose to accept the
light yes sir yeah oh here we go
[Applause]
[Applause]
what you don't notice is that all the
ones that went running away ran straight
off a cliff edge okay
okay okay down in the marshlands Arthur
can spot a snake of monumental
proportions it's dead and doesn't move
it's not that exciting but in my eyes
this is a reference to the Jungle Book
and the villainous giant snake car if
car is here then we could probably find
Moby - it looks like in this reality
Mowgli didn't go back to the man village
and instead kept with his North pack
he's around this area and if you can
keep up with the Wolfman he'll lead you
to his cave
I really wish he kept the orange
underwear why am I looking at management
issues move on a quick note about the
hermit living in the northern forests
hey you know he's from an old Monty
Python sketch about sociable Hermits I
am NOT a hermit I'm the king the king in
the 1920s the story of Dracula was
reinterpreted by a German man which
birthed the story of Nosferatu and once
again he can be found in Red Dead in
Sint Denis by locating his five
scriptures on the walls of buildings
he'll give away his next victims
location allowing us to interrupt so you
found me hey what are you doing
stay back for your own sake I walk with
the undead what your vampire I have been
called many names over the centuries now
go or I'll feed on you - you're a
goddamn idiot
I'll suck you dry come to me immortal
you are the seventh after hog-tying this
guy I wasn't sure how to dispose of him
I attempted to use the tram or trolley
but that um ended in a bloodbath Lee
there's a subtle nod to the walking dead
in red dead redemption - this is
Hershel's farm and if you can remember
that far back he decided to keep all the
infected in a barn waiting for the
plague to pass by the time Rick and the
group showed up and opened that barn
every single Walker died by a gunshot or
the occasional stabbing back in Red Dead
all those victims are buried nearby with
the same date on all tombstones and the
note about how they died
down in the swamps we are told about the
night folk effectively the zombies of
this world well it's possible to see
them in many ways for me I stumbled
across this girl from the ring and
without realizing I was already dead
[Music]
this is actually the home of a mystery
you can uncover if you can spot the
ghosts in the fog and listen to their
ramblings you can find out how that girl
died and what really happened to her
I'll be like me and die instantly Red
Dead Redemption too is packed with
references and callbacks to the original
games in the series something as simple
as John Martin's inability to swim is
brought up in conversation if you played
eight years ago you'll remember how damn
frustrating John's fear of water
in the open world it's possible to spot
Charles canoes flying machine which was
part of a side quest in the original Red
Dead you're gonna try to use that crazy
thing to fly I'll be soaring like an
eagle or my name's not Charles Kinnear
let's just say it didn't go too well for
him down in Sint Denis the mask from
undead nightmare the dlc from eight
years ago can be spotted that mask is
what caused the zombie outbreak here's a
strange one facies can be spotted in
tree carvings in West Elizabeth some
look to be images of characters from the
series such as mr. McFarlane and shadow
wolf from Red Dead Revolver others I
can't place help would be appreciated
Oh segue speaking of the McFarland's do
you remember Bonnie McFarlane she saved
us at the beginning of Red Dead
Redemption go to the beach here and
you'll find a dead body okay now he's a
dead body the note he gives us is a love
letter to Bonnie McFarlane Bonnie did go
on to find love in about 1913 so she
only has another 14 years to wait by the
way I tried to give this chap a burial
at sea but he's too damn buoyant I then
tried to put a few holes in him and
accidentally blew his head off sorry
dude
I'll tell Bonnie you send your love okay
I'm going to be a little bit spoiler
rific for the next few minutes if you
haven't finished the main campaign or if
you haven't seen the ending to Red Dead
Redemption 1 skip forward a little have
they gone good let's crack on so we take
control of Jim Milton at the end of the
story and he has a few Easter eggs to
show us there's a quite moment of pause
when John is about to kill his final
enemy on the ranch that pause signals
John's returning to his old ways but it
is also the exact same pose as that one
found on the front cover of Red Dead
Redemption 1 complete with sawn-off
shotgun one of the enemies John faces
early on is none other than the
great-great-great-great grandfather of
GTA protagonist Trevor Phillips he's
even voiced by the same actor Steven off
Oh careful boys careful look at this
tough guy get out of Trevor's
partner-in-crime Michael de Santa is
also in the game but I haven't seen him
yet he's one of the old Driscoll men
please let me know if you find him over
an armadillo there's a picture of a
strange man in Herbert Monstar who's
that I don't know it's just a little
portrait somebody gave me once I always
quite liked it why no reason just seem
familiar if you're unaware the strange
man was a character in the original Red
Dead with many people believing he was
the Grim Reaper tell me your name or I
won't be responsible for my actions oh
but you will damn you yes many have back
in the ps3 and xbox days a common glitch
would occur when playing Red Dead
Redemption the donkey would somehow be
replaced with a little old woman well
that is referenced in Easter Egg form
here on the map the donkey lady lived a
long life working to the bone and the
Easter egg I've been trying to find
since I first started playing where the
heck is red Harlow from Red Dead
Revolver well I'm still trying to find a
bloody answer to that but just like in
Red Dead a years ago The Legend of Red
Hollow will never die
visit camp sites around the world and if
you're lucky enough you'll hear this
yeah my brother he's dead now but he
used to tell me stories about red Harlow
legendary bounty hunter bringing the
savage outlaws of the frontier to
justice man who watched his parents get
murdered in front of him as a boy but
who uses that pain to become a better
man and ultimately to wreak his
vengeance so we all know how Jack
Marston killed at Garros while there's a
subtle easter egg mirroring this event
the first time Edgar Ross meets Jack is
in the same predicament this time Jack
is fishing when Ross arrives and the
tables are turned 15 years later what a
great piece of narrative symmetry
remember John's gravestone after his
passing it read blessed are the
peacemakers that saying is repeated as
the title of a mission in Red Dead
Redemption - and guess what it's one way
you're double-crossed again blessed are
the peacemakers for they shall be called
hey Molly where's Dutch well however it
goes I'm not sure their line of thought
serves you and me very well okay those
of you who didn't want spoilers can come
back now let's keep going with red dead
references I'm sure you've noticed
London rickets gets a nod as a cigarette
cart but he's also mentioned many times
in Red Dead Redemption - the first time
is when you are deputized by the law run
dhadak and poisoning folks with his
miracle cure from here two hands burg
kill Morton Landon Ricketts without even
pulling a trigger get some kind of sick
satisfaction out of it have you received
the noblest of men and a woman quest
don't ignore it it offers some of the
best weapons in the game simply view the
back of each photo to have it added to
your map when the quest line is complete
you'll get your hands on this revolver
notice the words canis can omit it that
roughly translates to dog-eat-dog
Rockstar fans will know this as a
reference to the game bully over in the
UK the game was released as canis canim
edit after the newspapers and media went
wax lyrical on the bullying aspect and
Rockstar were forced to change the title
speaking of bully the trophy for
completing Red Dead Redemption - is
named the same as the final chapter in
bully coincidence
I think not bully - confirmed I missed
this next one until around 30 hours into
the game take note of the names the gang
give themselves to hide their identity
many of them are characters from other
rockstar games for example what's your
name
Aiden O'Malley and that's the name of an
inmate in GTA 4 another one I noticed is
Rip Van Winkle he's not GTA related but
a literary nod to the american
short-story who are you Rip Van Winkle
huh one more reference to GTA before we
move on the sacred UFO which has been
watching us returns at the summit of
this mountain return after midnight to
see it flying in the air it leaves just
as quickly as it arrived as well as the
long-running gag with UFO
Rockstar also has a thing for Bigfoot
sightings if you've played undead
nightmare you'll know John has the
chance to kill the last Bigfoot who
tells him they've lived there for 1,000
years so it makes sense that they'd
return in Red Dead Redemption - there's
a few sightings to note the first is a
skeleton found on the path of the
mountain where the UFO was the second
Sasquatch could very well be the one
John talks to in the original Red Dead
Redemption this one takes a few steps
after scanning 30 types of animals make
your way up to this ravine from here
you'll spot a flock of birds taking
flight follow them and they'll lead you
to a lonely Bigfoot in the mountains you
see I'm too big I haven't got any
friends because I'm too big is that so
yes yes it is so that's sort of why I
said that because I was lonely and
wanted to talk his voice and Amina
seemed to be based on the monsters in
character abominable and his desire to
find friendship if you come back here in
three days you'll be rewarded with more
dialogue let's look at some random
events in Red Dead Redemption - that I
insist you look at in the gangs camp try
being antagonistic to everyone
eventually you'll be knocked out for
your troubles if you're extremely lucky
John Marston will do the honors
over in Lemoine we can see a ghost train
the best spot to stand is by this sign
camp until nighttime and then get back
into position and wait for about four
minutes in total you'll see the ghost
train roll through
yeah yep
downing the braithwaite's mana is a
hidden sibling she may be becoming one
of the undead or maybe this is how
insane people were treated back then
come back at the end of the game and
she's no longer in the land of the
living
oh my girlfriend is in this game she has
her own Easter Egg get yourself over to
the boarded up house in the Hills it's
impossible to get inside seemingly but
look up to the first floor of second
floor of your na and there's a window
open climb up to find the weirdest lab
in history there's tons of experiments
to look at and yeah on the wall it's my
girlfriend HIPPA Crocker Pig she's damn
gorgeous ever wondered what happened to
the bear that got away in the story take
a look at this Shack does a bear in the
woods not anymore
a triple Easter egg can be found here
a huge meteor has hit the world and
decimated the tree line a little further
south a part of that meteor has
absolutely obliterated a few locals
what's most interesting here is the
meteor shower in the sky at night [ __ ]
up a tent and gaze skyward
[Music]
we've looked at a few cameos made by GTA
characters in Red Dead Redemption
- well there's even more to find the
founders of Achievement Hunter are in
the game go talk to the proprietor of
the hotel in Valentine welcome welcome
come on in it's how did define the
second founder as he works at the train
stations around the world he's most
often found at Emerald ranch I see again
sir I must have done something mighty
bad to be worth all this so there we
have it 50 Easter eggs and references
found in Red Dead Redemption - I know
this tons more so please write them in
the comments and if we get enough I'll
make a follow-up video I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade I've been a pleasure
as always
I'll see you next time